Pues nada Juan,
estamos aquí en acorcón,
en el barrio de parque oeste,
que lleva 15 años esperando la apertura
de 1 Centro de salud
que afortunadamente dentro de nada VA a haber abiertas
sus puertas. Pero desde el ayuntamiento de Alcorcón,
desde el partido socialista
estamos reivindicando desde hace muchísimo tiempo
y te agradecemos mucho que hayas venido a apoyarnos eh,
que este Centro tiene que abrirse como Centro Nuevo,
¿con plantilla nueva
y no derivada de otro Centro de salud
eh? Que en este caso es el Miguel Servet.
El Miguel Servet atiende a 19 000 personas,
este Centro de salud a 16 000.
No puede ser que los recursos de allí se pasen aquí
para que al final ni esto funcione
ni el Miguel Servet tampoco. Ujum.
Pues oye,
todo mi apoyo totalmente y muchas Gracias por defender
eh, los intereses de la familia de acorcón.
O sea, lo que no puede ser es que de cuánta gente mayor
en el Centro del municipio
se VA a quedar sin su médico de toda la vida de Dios
porque lo van a traer para acá
porque no son capaces de aquí tener la plantilla nueva
que esto merece. Yo creo que ya está bien
de tener que estar en 2 023 en la familia de acorcón,
mendigando pediatras y mendigando médicos.
La Comunidad de Madrid ve a tomarse esto en serio
y empezar a a Dar Paso de verdad y además Dar pasos eh,
que no Sean en falso,
porque en marzo vino la Presidenta Ayuso
y inauguró el Centro.
Sin vigencia, sin pediatra,
sin médicos, sin enfermeros y enfermeras
y al día de hoy
estamos a 27 de noviembre
y siguen las puertas cerradas.
Estas y luego también nos preocupa mucho y tú lo sabes,
el ensanche sur
sabes que es 1 barrio que hicimos hace muchos años,
que lo has visitado con nosotros y con nosotras.
Y allí de la misma manera
hace 15 años cedimos 1 parcela que no está como esta,
está totalmente eh, sin construir nada
y que son miles de familias las que están esperando.
Pues esa, um, esa atención médica eh,
que sea de 1 forma digna,
no para 1 barrio tan grande como el ensanche sur
totalmente. A Ayuso le encanta hacerse fotos y
hacer anuncios, pero luego gestionar y trabajar poco,
así que para eso estamos aquí,
para exigir que haga su tarea y para apoyaros.
Seguiremos investigando.
Muchísimas Gracias, adelante